so 20 years ago the u.s government built
a massive national security state to
fight the threat from
islamic extremism that entire
apparatus has now been turned on the
american population itself
the white supremacists that joe biden
says live
in our midst white supremacy joe biden
has told us is the greatest threat this
country faces
what is it exactly who are these people
why have none been arrested
no one's asked that question no one in
congress has not even republicans
why is that exactly david horowitz is a
long time conservative writer but he
began his career on the hard left he's
the son of communists
he understands exactly what's happening
he's been predicting it for quite a bit
of time we just spoke to david horowitz
for a brand new episode of tucker
carlson today
here's part of that conversation
[Music]
republicans are poor defenders of our
country because they're poor
messengers the democrats
control and have controlled every major
city
inner city in america for 50 to 100
years
control them a hundred percent every
injustice
real uh or imagined
in the inner cities done to minorities
and the black people in particular
democrats are 100 responsible for
and yet republicans are too polite to
ever mention this
it's as though they don't want to
embarrass their enemies by confronting
them with their worst crimes
so the everything that we've seen all
these protests
uh in this tearing up the cities which
was
over the summer which were done with
democrat support
uh these racist mayors
largely black and or and 100 percent
democrat
uh encouraged the riots uh did not call
out the proper forces to
suppress them uh to arrest these people
uh allowed them to occupy our cities and
burn them there were
over 600 violent
violent riots in 220 american cities
this is the problem in our country
everything's upside down
the racism in our country is an epidemic
of
anti-white racism you can say anything
about white people
you can fling terms like white supremacy
around
um with no evidence no basis in in
reality america
is not a racist society in the in the
least
and you know joe biden what has he said
the greatest threat is not isis it's not
china it's it's not the iranian
terrorists
the greatest threat to america is white
supremacy well he must be talking about
himself
because he's been a lifelong white
supremacist
and i guess he's doing some kind of
what he thinks is a personal atonement
by dumping that charge
uh unjustly on his country uh
but it's a monstrous lie you know
why aren't republicans referring to the
democrats as the racists that they are
this is a racist
party the equity programs
are designed to help black people
and minorities like small business
people
but not whites how racist is that
yet the only republican i know who's
called a democrat or racist is donald
trump
that's why they hate donald trump
republicans have to stop being so nice
and going along with this language
control
um you know the border crisis
this is treason you can't blow up the
southern
border in the midst of a pandemic uh
it's not only i mean the conservative
estimate is that a hundred thousand
coronavirus carriers will come in
illegally into the country this year
thanks to the democrats
but of course there's the you know the
billion-dollar cartels that they're
empowering
there are the sex traffickers people are
dying
you don't hear rhetoric coming from the
republican party
that even approaches the
seriousness of the problem that the
democrats have created
they're betrayed the country
our conversation with david horowitz
fascinating went on for about an hour
you can find it on
foxnation.com under tucker carlson today
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else